there are some doors that it's they're
easy to get into but you shouldn't go
through them
right there's some people that just
don't have your best interests at heart
what is the producer's rep it's like a
sales agent
it's another name for a sales agent so
um
in the
it usually connotes being a domestic
sales agent as opposed to an
international sales agent
it's a little different in that
as a producer rep you are
selling films to us distributors
and in doing so there's you don't really
have to take over the film from the
filmmaker you can
make the deal you can negotiate on their
behalf and then they can deliver the
film to the distributor and distributor
can pay them directly it's a fairly easy
transaction
whereas on the international front
international sales agents really have
to take over that process so
international sales agents are more like
distributors
in that you deliver them the film
and then they go to markets around the
world sell these distributors and then
in turn
deliver the film to those distributors
collect that money and then account to
a um
a producer
so in my case i don't do it i don't do
that i specialize in us distributors
and
as most producer reps do
and i'm just i'm like a like a
consultant sales agent for that purpose
what's the difference between a
producer's rep and a distributor
so a producer rep is really trying to
get the film maker the best deal
possible in the united states with a
with a traditional distributor
um
distributors are are taking on the film
put it in theaters
putting on video and demand
making blu-rays
selling the rights to netflix or hbo and
putting on advertising video on demand
later like 2b or pluto so they're
usually most distributors are handling
all rights that way
as a producer rep
i'm
meeting the filmmaker usually about the
time they've finished the film or
about to get in the film festival or
just got into a film festival and i'm
gonna help them
get into the world of distribution and
show the film to the distributors to see
who would be the best possible partner
for taking the film out
why would a filmmaker hire a producer
rep
well especially if you're a first-time
filmmaker
most schools don't teach film
distribution
and so there's just a huge learning gap
in terms of like what distribution is
and what they do and usually i consider
my part of my job as education in terms
of teaching my clients what distributors
do and which distributors do it better
than who
and part of my job is to know who's
doing it legitimately and who's not
doing it legitimately and who takes an
appropriate
distribution fee
for putting the film out into the world
who's kind of trying to rip them off
and so it's to protect them as well
um
so there's there's really just the
knowledge of distribution that's one
reason another is just protection
um
uh in in addition some salesmanship um
i'm trying to get the best possible
deal out there and some filmmakers you
know a filmmaker in in theory could wear
all those hats and they got to learn the
distribution landscape and learn who all
the distributors are
and learned how to negotiate these the
contracts
and had a sales hat in addition to a
creative hat there are those types right
that that could do it all
um i'm here for the ones that don't you
know and producer ups in general are
there for the people who who can't you
know that need some help in that in that
area
have you ever experienced that where
someone says you know i went to afm i go
on imdb pro and i see what similar films
are who they're with and i just can't
navigate this can you help me
yeah all the time because there's um
there are a lot of different kinds of
people at afm like they're sales agents
versus distributors
sometimes they're they do both
there's been increasing trend of some
international sales agents getting into
u.s distribution
their contracts look a little bit
different than what u.s distributors
agreements look like
and so
yeah i get it all the time that from
filmmakers you know a they can't get the
distributors to call them back
you know there are some distributors
that are pretty good have an open door
policy of looking at lots of material
and there's some distributors that just
want to really use the system of agents
and reps that are out there
to to kind of be a
um
kind of a buffer against all the content
that's out there they don't need to see
10 000 movies a year they want to look
at the top three or 400 in which to
choose the 20 they might distribute that
year
so um
it just yeah
most most filmmakers
um
when they go to afm afm is a great
learning process but it's not a great
really
great tool for independent filmmaker to
go to and actually sell their own film
it usually
they experience it once
they'll they'll find it's really hard to
get in those doors to meet with
distributors and most distributors and
sales agents want to
keep keep the wolves at bay
so to speak
right so if a filmmaker says well i'm
very hands-on and diy i'll i'll be the
one to break through it's kind of like
they're breaking protocol a little bit
that's not how yeah it's well it's not
that it's not okay um it's just that
there are there are some companies that
it's just hard to get a return phone
call they're just busy dealing with the
reps and agents for film and they're
they're getting some of these companies
are getting five
six submissions a day
and some of them they just completely
ignore they just look at it and think i
don't know what that is there's just
there's just too much incoming
um so it helps to have someone that
knows them
that says hey i can vouch this is
something you should take a look at it's
not crazy for you to look at this you
may not like it you may love it but it's
something you should you know pay
attention to
um
you know
that that's one aspect of it but it
even more than that
um
there are some doors that it's they're
easy to get into but you shouldn't go
through them
right there's some people that just
don't have your best interests at heart
they're just there's a lot of um
in my opinion companies that just don't
do it properly and take exorbitant fees
um don't cap their costs don't do things
that they should do to to to help their
the their client the filmmaker
um you know maximize revenues for them
as well as for the company that took on
the film
so um
um
yes there's there's multiple reasons to
have a rep um i think you know beyond
just being able to get in the door
um
but i you know i've known there are also
people that make film after film after
film and establish relationships
where they can just do that themselves
as well especially first-time
second-time filmmakers that have a
hardest time which are most independent
filmmakers
um
at the end of the day of the of the ten
thousand made a year it's nine thousand
plus they're either first-timers
um
you know to to a certain degree
so it's not just um
helping you get in the door it's also
maybe helping you uh stay away from
doors that are open that yeah you
shouldn't be venturing into for sure and
and even if you knew
it's also maximizing the best possible
situation
um even if you get in all the right
doors
um
you know it is helpful to have someone
that's had a a deal through this
distributor and how to fill film through
this streamer and knows what it's like
to be in bed with them to those you know
how good are they at communication how
good are they returning your phone calls
what do their royalty reports look like
do they send them to you consistently
because it's not only the contract you
have to worry about it's the behavior
behind the contract
right because it's fairly easy for
distributors to kind of ignore a lot of
different aspects of their contract
because it's just the distribution
contracts are just hard to sue on
they're all very distributor friendly
distributors are not going to make
overtly producer friendly contracts in
general
so even more important the contract is
is the habits and behavior
and you know have been in the business
for 25 years i've just seen a lot of a
lot of behavior
so to speak so
um
um i think that's pretty helpful
sure and these are these are contracts
that only the distributor
draws up like someone couldn't say i
i've actually have my own boilerplate
plate card yeah no they it's always a
distributor's contract in fact you
should be actually wary if it's not
their contract because that probably
indicates they don't know better and
they haven't been doing it very long i
have seen that before where i got it
actually not too long ago someone came
to me with a film and they already had
an offer from someone and i said okay um
did they have a did they send you a
contract i could look at for you and
they said no they wanted us to sit and
do the contract
i said well there they can't be that
sophisticated if they if they're out
there acquiring films and wanting you
know you to come up with the contract
that's just pretty pretty
it's a good sign that there's just not
very savvy